he's a tough guy on TV and in film but
he wanted no piece of Fritzie when he
walked in Mark Wahlberg here actor
producer are you worried about getting
injured if you arm wrestle fritzy you
know it's pretty intimidating you know
is that the hair on his arms that
intimidated that Barham looking strength
yeah you know it's the guy you don't
know it's like you go to SEAL training
yeah all the guys you think oh my god
this guy's a badass he's gonna make it
he's gonna be those aren't the guys that
make it's a little weird guy in the
corner
that's the the tough crazy guy what's
the reaction on the street when you come
to New York um I don't know I don't come
that often and it usually is just the
same kind of people of following you and
uh you know sometimes people recognize
me sometimes they don't but I and I move
pretty much under the radar but so
you're not if you go to a sporting event
or anything when's the last time you
went to a sporting event here in New
York gosh I don't even remember I think
the last time I went to uh I don't know
it had to have been the Knicks game when
will and I were shooting for the other
guys I don't have a tendency to visit
New York sporting events all that much
not really my cup of tea when's the last
time he went to something in Boston we
actually went Pete Berg and I were
shooting Patriots day in Boston we went
uh early on a day game to shoot with
with poppy I mean you said at the time
when I talked to you after that that he
told you he was just tired yeah when he
said why wouldn't you come back meeting
homered again last night
unbelievable yeah he's putting up the
numbers are crazy but I bet he told you
that he was just too tired and he said
he's tired he said the body's told him
that he's done you know but I mean
they're playing at that level I would
imagine you know guys always want to
keep going further than they're supposed
to and for longer than they're supposed
to and I guess he's just maybe he'll
change his mind I don't know how do you
do your own stunts are you allowed to
only which I yes but only what's
required but a movie like this with
Deepwater Horizon of course you have the
real guy there and you want to make it
as realistic as possible so I'll do
anything that's required but I didn't
like the fact that Pete Berg lit me on
fire
actually lit me on fire but wait explain
it so well the whole rig you know
there's a blowout and the rig starts to
explode and there are major fires and
explosions all over the rig so there's a
point where we're actually going into
another room to try to turn on the the
secondary generator and so Pete thought
it'd be cool if you know we were on fire
before we went into the room so you know
they doused us with all this protective
gel and then of course they put all the
flammable stuff on us and the guy
standing there and he lights us and then
they're not even rolling it and then
it's myself and Dylan O'Brien we're on
fire and he's freaked out you know so
he's like he's supposed to be putting me
out and I'm putting him out but he's
punching me in the face and everything
else and it was pretty chaotic I I liked
it Pete Berg let you guys on fire he he
wasn't lit on fire while watching you oh
he's on fire inside yeah he's already
inside but no he you know no but but I
think if I asked Pete to do it for me he
would have done it for me when's the
last time a director yelled at you uh
Michael Bay yeah about maybe about a
month ago would you do I didn't do
anything I didn't do anything I was just
standing there you know it he he doesn't
yell to the point where you try to yell
at you it's just he it there's it's so
crazy you know with all the explosions
in action and everything else that uh
you know and he's basically leading the
whole charge you know he kind of
controls the whole set so he just has a
tendency to raise his voice but now he's
since we were shooting in England
he's been very chill this is
transformers yes trans what number is
this 5 5 transformer 5 but you look at
the director is sort of he's your your
coach humanities the coach he's the guy
you never check yeah he's the guy who's
you know it's his vision that I'm
servicing and I'm there to kind of give
him what he needs how do you deal with a
bad director uh usually I try to avoid
working with them but have you ever
gotten in a situation uh I've been in
situations where things got a little
hairy and I've worked with inexperienced
directors and then very experienced
directors so it is different if I'm
producing the movie and I I kind of
brought the director on then it's
probably a little bit different than
working with a writer director
like Pete or a guy like Michael where
you basically there to services vision
how did this story come about Oh
actually Lorenzo de Bono Ventura called
me and he said did you read the New York
Times piece about the Deepwater Horizon
and I said no and I like everybody else
what I had seen on the media was really
about the environmental disaster and the
the big oil spill and once I read the
piece and the script I realized oh my
god eleven people lost their lives and
that wasn't really the focus of any of
the media coverage and I just thought
that was strange you know that they
pretty much ignored the fact that 11
people lost their lives and so we were
we wanted to make the movie but we
wanted to focus on the human element of
the story and of course when we said we
wanted to make the movie the families
were reluctant because of the fact that
nobody really acknowledged that the loss
and once we were able to communicate to
them what our intentions were and then
Pete and I showed them on Survivor then
they they got on board and really
supported us what is it about real
stories though it seems to hit something
inside of you a perfect storm Patriot a
fighter those are the ones that resonate
those are the ones that that have a real
impact on people I mean those are the
kind of movies and stories that I
gravitate towards so you know and you
always you always the reward whether the
movie's a success at the box office and
not is so much greater being a part of
something like that it's no longer about
your own individual experience as an
actor it's really about coming together
as a whole to tell the story and honor
these people and and that's really
special and they were they were heroes
and Mike Williams who I play in the
movie he hates the term hero he just as
a regular guy he would have done it he'd
do it again
tomorrow and he knows his brothers would
have done it to save him and it's just
his job but you know they did some
pretty incredible thing he's Mark
Wahlberg actor producer no longer
singing right no rapping nothing well
you got to tell I still got the power
that's as good as I can think I'm gonna
tell you people always like how did you
sing so bad look at my daughter's mortar
okay
is mortified if I busted out an old rap
right now she would die she wouldn't she
doesn't wanna speak to me now
yeah Marx how old is your daughter she
is 13 oh my god the big 13 okay and
she's now she's been asking me on all
these interviews that I do to do the yep
yep game so every other question that
you asked me now I'm going to respond
first response will be yep yep then I'll
I will ask I will answer the question
then I will follow they yep yep now
she's happy yeah I said the up yep she
can do
she's got Pauly's microphone there she
wants to say something dad I want to
hear you rap no she just said it okay
you know what let's take a break here
okay cuz you might have to refresh
yourself with the lyrics okay no no no I
got a rap right now you're gonna rap
right now uh-huh okay
I'm your 45 year old father and I got a
rap and if you keep misbehaving I'm
gonna give you behind a slap and it's
called a spanking and if later on in
life you're gonna thank me there's all
the advice that I'm giving you is good
for you and if not your button behinds
gonna be black and blue all right oh
don't don't cut it down we giving you a
positive encouragement rappin good
information to help you behave and then
you're gonna earn that phone back girl
learn a solo there's it no she's a mad
dog face you lost the phone yes
but I'm encouraging her to not only earn
the phone back but keep the phone good
behavior is the key to success in life
but my brothers or anything didn't lose
the phone when they were just never mad
they don't have fun they have iPad but
it's but if I took the iPad they
wouldn't care they just go throw a ball
or bounce a half the wall is to me happy
you you live for the phone so I gotta
get you where it counts kid how else do
I get you to change we'll see if we can
patch up the Wahlberg's right after this
they're here on the Dan Patrick show
Mark Wahlberg plays oil rig engineer
Mike Williams in the new film Deepwater
Horizon in theaters on September 30th
here in the man cave and we're watching
the father-daughter experience here I'm
reliving this since I have three
daughters that are older than your
daughter who's 13 and I like this he
looks very happy there's not you're not
the cool dad I would think you would be
the cool dad did you know what if she
just asked me if she could meet Rihanna
or beyoncé then I'm the cool dad if I
can deliver ooh the big name can you do
that uh she's not doing nothing right
now until the behavior turns but you
know what I want her to and I will make
it happen I've gone out of my way to
call da Harry from a new direction in
one direction and Justin Bieber i'ma
call them all yeah Niall or Harry yeah
Harry come right over to the house he
was nice enough he did he's a fine young
lad he was sitting in my living room and
I was like move what are you doing
did you have any advice for him uh do
you experience what you experienced is
it similar is you know that pop stardom
no I think it's it's just now with
social media and everything you then
they live under such a microscope that
they don't really have the opportunity
to out there and make mistakes and
experience life and experiment I you
know I did all that stuff and I was in
lots of trouble before I had any success
so by the time I had success I realized
okay well this is nice I've I've
experienced the other side let me kind
of clean up my act to behave myself do
your kids know like what you were that
hole not all mark uh uh a little bit a
little bit but not that much and they
don't know much before that but I do try
to explain to them you know that I dad
had been trouble and dad works really
hard because dad came from nothing and I
want to provide a better life for them
but I also want to lead by example and
show that hard work is the way to
achieve your goals and doing the right
thing what about your movies how do you
introduce your movies to your kids only
well there's movies that they can't they
saw daddy's home they haven't seen Ted
she's probably seen everything she's
more computer savvy than she's 13
yeah they built a find a way to yeah to
see those things what movies did
of mine do you want to see that you
haven't seen um mom got me the lovely
bones on my iPad oh the plane today but
um I haven't seen anything okay I've
only seen daddy's home and transformers
what about invisible I've seen though oh
cool
but not Ted I saw it with like no sound
cuz he was watching with headphones I
stood by I showed them the fight scene
from Ted Oh with no sound I've seen
something and then they will really
wanted to see oh my boys were like daddy
was whipping you in the butt we want to
see that I remember I think you might
have been on Howard Stern talking about
Ted when it was just first coming out
and and the whole premise I thought it's
crazy ridiculous and but you have to
allow yourself to just go I'm I got it
my best friend's a teddy bear I gotta
fight him like when they pitch it to you
which the look on your face it's an
impossible pitch just like it's
impossible to go and try to sell the
movie but then when I finally
reluctantly read the script I'm thirty
pages in I'm like wow this is like one
of the great buddy comedies of all time
and you forget that it's a teddy bear so
then you have to go and you see the
technology and Seth kind of walked me
through his vision and then I just
believed and I said you know I'm gonna
take the plunge and then I went try to
tell my wife and she was like you're an
idiot it sounds ridiculous I don't get
you Anna Teddy talking teddy bear forget
it it's over your career is over and it
was just one of those things where you
know you had to kind of just go with it
and believe it and trust him and it
worked so there are some laughs out
there lines in there that Seth has that
are just yeah their time in it still
it's the highest-grossing r-rated comedy
of all time
crazy Anne didn't make 550 million I
made 50 million in Japan and in American
comedies
no American comedies work in Japan how
it will Ferrell is not afraid to be
naked when you worked with him daddy's
daddy's home you you have your shirt off
a few times in there yeah um do you
write it do you want it in the script no
I don't want it in the script because he
seems to get naked in a lot of his movie
he likes it he likes it right he writes
it in high whitey I kind of cringe with
that stuff it'd only be
when I obviously I took my shirt off all
the time when I was rapping in them with
the Calvin Klein stuff I was known for
having my shirt off
so when I wanted to become an actor and
be taken seriously I wanted to get as
far away from that stuff as possible
that's why with Boogie Nights it was
like I really wanted to make sure that I
changed my appearance as much as
possible that's why I lost so much
weight and you know because I wanted
people to try to you know to be taken
seriously which is not an easy thing to
do transitioning from that kind of
career to tactic what about sports as I
know Pete Berg likes you know you did
Friday Night Lights but how important is
sports in anything down the road
obviously ballers you're involved in but
movie wise is there a sports story left
to be told that wouldn't uh yeah it's
funny we we still talked about doing a
version of the fight or the war gaudy
trilogy and how that relationship was
formed even though they inflicted so
much pain and damage on each other and
then don't LeBron and I are talking
about doing a basketball movie had a
fantasy camp type of movie with these
guys my crew comes down and invades this
fantasy camp and then LeBron and I have
this major conflict kind of craziness in
Vegas and the whole thing so we actually
met he came to my house and we're trying
to find a writer right now to kind of
rework the script Doug Allen actually
did the first on this on the script um
so I'd like to do that and you know if I
get one more crack yet being on the
baseball diamond or you know anywhere
else in a field I would like to do it
but now I'm thinking realistically I can
be a coach instead of a player ooh which
you know it you think you know that kind
of stinks but for me playing the young
kid and then getting to play the father
I'm just lucky that I was able to make
it that long and had the career that
I've had uh the Garoppolo injury you're
concerned about that would you have your
shoulder would you trade your shoulder
for Garoppolo right now just so we could
play no you would know but I like a
problem what if it was Brady if Brady
needed it ah no no no no I got too much
to do man I got to I got to put torn
labrum as in both shoulders anyway you
know those that were all the old excuse
here that he doesn't want a piece of you
fritzy the old Toledo what I want put me
in the game
I can scramble were you I can Huck at
forty fifty yard were you any good as an
athlete in high school I never mom I can
tell you a question
okay with your daughter here I didn't do
anything in high school
so but it also they didn't have any
sports at the high school that I went to
there was no gym there was no teams if
you wanted to play you had to go and
play with another school I had an
opportunity I was very young to play the
boys club was going to see if they could
get us a scholarship to the Boston
College high school or Don Bosco or
great school we could actually play
sports but I misbehaved then things
didn't work out so I had to go and start
from square one but that was one of the
big regrets for me um but you and your
brothers to do like were you good
amongst them
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm like play
football basketball baseball hockey
boxing you know we played all the sports
but but especially hockey and football
very expensive sports to play yeah you
know with equipment and traveling and
all that stuff so we never really got to
play organized sports is there somebody
you haven't met with Boston sports mmm
no metamour pretty much yeah pretty much
yeah been very force you want to be
involved in a team absolutely have you
ever thought about trying to buy one
with something I always yeah I mean we
were talking about putting a bid in for
the Clippers
with a group of guys um every time I see
mr. Kraft it's on you know then he can
my little minority station
you know I got money Kraft is a great
guy I just showed the Deepwater Horizon
to the whole team but I think I think
we're going to be good at the fact that
we're to a know is pretty good I think
if they they said we went one in three
without Tom and then went on to win the
division I think everybody would have
been happy and I think we're set is
really good I think he can move so you
know I think we going squeak we went out
with the Texans and then we can stomp
the bills it get Tom a little more
practice on our by and then go beat up
on the Browns I we brought this up last
week side to go get my license at the
DMV do you go to the DMV um yes you have
to go to the DMV wait a minute
I go to the DMV using a deal he comes to
my no I don't stand in line wait well I
didn't have to stay in the line last
time I went well what happened I was
able to go and kind of go into the back
and somebody was kind enough to help me
out and I sign the paper and took but I
took as many pictures as it would have
taken to stand in line uh your your
daughter has a question for you yes
darling lovey you hesitate when they ask
about what if you go well because I
don't want to seem like I have this
sense of entitlement about me well I
guess then you have to get a friend I
had how do you think I get my life
because you're in school or you're
sleeping so yeah I don't
yeah next time I'll take you with me to
the DMV but Cindy you know somebody had
to be a V so yeah I got my license where
do you think I get it you think it just
comes in the mail or they bring the
photo thing to my house ya know so you
you you've got a couple days with your
daughter now London and then Paris yeah
I'm excited
yep she got I woke her up at the crack
of dawn today and she was not happy I
said you're coming with that did he it's
daddy-daughter dig uh-huh let me ask
your daughter what she thought of the
how did you think dad did in the
interview this one yeah yeah good yeah
do it okay
oh good it's most fun when all that I
got the what what's in there no you
didn't actually you didn't say I just
said it again on what it's not that's
not the word you just talked about it
and why'd you say I didn't say you say
like this yep yep dad did good in the
interview yep yep Oh yep you you talk
kept cups yep yep so so you got to say
it just had a random time you talk yeah
I remember yep this is just a phase it's
better five years five year you got to
run see my buddy Rasta Phil over there
so we have not one more to the entre he
has a performance inspired nutrition
shirt on which is our sports nutrition
line myself and Tom Dowd but I told him
with you yeah with that belly I think
you know just to wear a Wahlburgers
shirt you know it's a better
advertisement for burgers than
performance inspired nutrition what is
it yup yup did you say like this yep yep
and then you say yep yep um my dad Oh
like whatever you want me to say that
yep yeah
my dad like whatever you'll get mark
Mulder yeah place oil rig yep yep Mike
Williams in the new film yep yep
Deepwater Horizon in theaters yep yep
September 30th
yep yep yeah yeah see you buddy hey yo
yeah I guess why he has this job I just
come as the guest I couldn't do this
yep yep he's mark wall to see his name
on the wall there his dad Patrick for a
reason the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]